here today to talk about moocs and the
older learner
um
i'm coming from the osher lifelong
learning institute at uc berkeley and
i'll talk a little bit about what the
osher lifelong learning institute is
we're called ollie at berkeley for short
and i'm also a masters candidate at uc
berkeley in the school of public health
and in the school of social welfare
you might be wondering what
i'm doing here in design track i'm not a
designer i'm not an educator
my experience with moocs has been at
ollie at berkeley putting them on for
some older adults and doing blended
learning
but my specialty in school is in aging
and i'm specializing in the health and
the welfare of older adult populations
and so i kind of come with this
background
and knowledge of working with older
adults
in many different areas of my life so
that's why i'm here
um so to give you a little background at
ollie at berkeley um so we're a
year-round program for adults aged 50
and older
we offer non-credit courses as well as
lectures special events interest circles
and we also have research that we do
um
the research arm consists of myself
susan hoffman who's the executive
director of ollie at berkeley and then
we have an advisory team that's composed
of ali members who also tend to be
retired uc berkeley faculty who have
experience conducting their own research
and a couple of them are actually
current faculty members at uc berkeley
still
so there's 119
ollies nationwide and they're funded by
the bernard osher foundation
and we're the only ones that we're aware
of that actually has this research
component
we
we look at research as a way for us to
kind of keep
both on the cutting edge of making sure
that we're applying neuroscience
findings into the classroom as well as
conducting our own research to kind of
understand the learning experiences of
older adults
we also really strongly advocate for
including
in the research
including the voices and the experiences
of healthy older adults you know i think
so often we
we look at the experiences of um
you know sick frail older people and
there's a really wide variety of
experiences
and also looking at what some of the
positive aspects of aging and what older
adults can add to
the environment
and finally as i said like we really
strive to incorporate any research
findings directly into the classroom
experience so that it's it's a really
you know utilitarian research that we do
so i want to talk to you a little bit
about why we should pay attention to
older learners
the first is
i like to think of moocs as having a
great potential as an intervention um
i'm come from a public health background
and a social work background so that
might be why i have that idea
um but with older people especially that
continued intellectual stimulation that
moocs can offer as well as the
opportunities for like continued social
engagement i think that's something that
can be really powerful um for all people
but especially for older learners
um these you know that continued
engagement continued intellectual
stimulation can really bolster health
and wellness in later ages
um
you might be thinking you know there are
lots of organizations that cater to
seniors
and ali is one of them you know we only
offer courses for people older than 50.
but i think that these specialized
organizations kind of add to this
phenomenon we see in our society of
separating out older people and keeping
them separate from other generations and
so i think moocs offer a really unique
idea of ways that we can foster
intergenerational learning
also in my work as a social work intern
i've had adult children turn to their
aging parents in their office and go mom
why don't you join a senior center why
don't you do this adult day health thing
and i'll have the senior turn to me and
go
oh those are full of old people
i don't want to go there
and so kind of this idea of that you
know this is a way moocs could be a
platform for people that might not want
to just hang out with other older people
to get this intergenerational experience
um another point to this of this
learning the value of learning in older
ages
to draw also from my social work i had a
client who
extremely isolated man his wife had died
his family had no family his friends had
died he was living alone he came into my
office and i was expecting
a host of problems
um he had one of the most cheerful
demeanors i'd ever seen
and i said you know what do you do with
your time
what are you doing in your house all day
he goes oh i'm learning
he was teaching himself french and
spanish from books and then he'd rent
videos and he'd watch the subtitles and
he'd connect the learning and so he was
learning these languages
he said you know my health i can't
travel anymore my wife's gone and we
used to travel together but i can have
the world come to me through these
languages
and he was very low income because i had
said to him you know have you thought
about taking classes doing something
like that it wasn't something that he
could afford to do
and i thought wow like this is a guy
that moocs could be a really interesting
concept for him if he was able to kind
of access the platforms and get into
them so just thinking about kind of
moocs as a public health intervention is
something that can really benefit a lot
of people
the next thing are demographics you know
if you look around the room it's a
pretty small group that's in here and
this is typical for any time that we
talk about older people
it's a small world that
are actually interested in working with
older adults
i come from the bay area and
you know i see the same people over and
over
we're talking about 20 of the population
is going to be over 65 by 2030. the
fastest fastest growing demographic in
this country is people over 85. and so
this is a huge demographic
and there's not a whole ton of interest
or people that are focusing on this and
so there's a missed opportunity i think
in moocs that we could really start
focusing on older adult learners and
tailoring some things to older adult
learners
the next thing is risk factors you know
i got a little bit into this as far as
moocs is intervention
but older adults are more at risk for
things like depression for social
isolation
cognitive decline you know hearing and
vision loss and so the more that we can
kind of
mitigate these factors through this
concept of a mucus intervention
and then also consider these factors
when we're designing moocs
the more that we can make this
accessible for everyone
and then help with these risk factors
finally there's going to be increasing
numbers of people that are homebound and
so they're unable to lose their homes
sorry to leave their homes and so for
those individuals
what happens you know what are you doing
when you're at home all day and you
can't go anywhere what if you had access
to a learning institution's many
learning institutions online you knew
how to use the the technology and you
could go online and you could learn and
you could interact with other people
it could help combat boredom and
isolation this feeling of helplessness
of not being useful anymore
and so as we look at increasing numbers
of people that are homebound moocs could
be a way to to kind of add to people's
lives
um
there might be neurocognitive advantages
to this like continued intellectual
stimulation
and so if we look at the numbers for
dementia
nearly one in three older adults dies
with some form of dementia according to
the alzheimer's association
by 2050 we're looking at 1.2 trillion in
costs for alzheimer's
anything that we can do even to delay
the onset by a year by months by 2 years
is going to be emotional physical and
cost savings for individuals and
families in our systems
and so if we can look into ways of you
know forming an evidence base for how
moocs could potentially be a
neurocognitive intervention
i think that would be really excellent
and you can't do that unless you're
looking at a population of older people
all right
so the research that we did at all at
berkeley um was looking at two groups of
individuals
very small numbers right we did
qualitative research we did participant
observation
they were pretty informal
and so the first group was people aged
80 and older
and we were looking at them taking a
mooc on their own time and then coming
into classrooms and discussing
everything from content but also the
technology any barriers they had and
things like that
the second group we had six people and
they were aged 50 and they also went up
to their 80s and so the profile of these
individuals um
highly educated most of our ali members
have at least a ba
many of them have graduate and other
professional degrees many of them are
retired uc berkeley faculty
they're highly motivated you know
there's been a lot of talk this
conference about motivation and how to
motivate learners and older learners
tend by and large to be people that have
an intrinsic motivation because they are
desiring to learn not to get grades not
to get a certificate not for their to
further their career but really for the
sake of learning
um
and so
especially in this group that we studied
we're looking at groups that are very
much motivated to take moocs as well so
they were all self-selected that they
wanted to take moocs um relatively tech
savvy everyone had computer access
internet access
people you know some people had a little
bit of background in moocs some people
had no idea what they were um
and then the gender ratio most lifelong
learning we're looking at 70 women 30
percent men in our experiments here we
found that it was more like 50 50. so
more men seem to be interested in this
concept of online learning
um
so i just wanted to talk about the
profile for a second longer and that
this profile is important because if
these
the findings that we had
apply to this group with like highly
educated highly motivated if you're
looking at the older adults that are
most at risk for things like dementia
and poor health those are generally
people with less education less income
and so these findings can really show us
kind of the holes and where we should
also look further but also saying like
if this group is having trouble
what would these other groups be doing
in this case
so just really quickly it moves over 80.
so we have something that's called a
fourth age salon which is basically like
we get the fourth age is another word
for people over 80.
and so for three years we've been
putting these on and it's to help us
better understand and reduce barriers
amongst our older members and so we held
them once a month and
actually last year in the fall we
dedicated four of our fourth age salons
specifically to moocs
so
this is kind of that's the course that
we did what a plant knows through
coursera
and then
with the over 50s same idea but it was
an actual course that people registered
for
and then we had five classroom
discussions and we focus on this mooc
the history and future of mostly higher
education and that mooc
actually went into moocs so it was sort
of this meta interesting course
and so and then we had everyone talk you
know the technicalities of the mooc
platform people came prepared to class
with their notes
content what they thought of the
teaching styles if they had takeaways
things they would change so we gathered
a ton of qualitative data
yeah sure so i can go back so the first
group had seven people
and the second group had six
and then i have we have some transcripts
and then pages and pages of notes that i
took throughout it because there was a
lot of a lot of qualitative data that
was gathered
so small but
big
um so main takeaways
are that you know we need to be thinking
about these barriers that might come as
a result of aging and as a result of
comfort with technology um especially
because of hearing and vision
differences
and the different ease and understanding
of technology that these are things
these are special needs that we need to
pay attention to so that we're
mitigating those barriers instead of
just saying like oh all right well here
take it or leave it here's the platform
and i think by maximizing the usability
of moocs for older adults will also
benefit other groups
people with disabilities english
language learners those who might have
limited knowledge or experience of
technology due to like lifelong access
issues so this isn't just about older
adults with these changes
there's tremendous benefits
to
you know expanding our platforms to be
more inclusive of older adults
i think
looking at how the ways that their
knowledge and experience can add depth
to the peer-to-peer learning experience
it's really important
we had a retired physicist who was
actually like mentally fact-checking
things in the mooc as it went along and
so he'd come to class and be like well i
don't think this was correct and then
he'd come with pages of evidence that he
found and looked up and so those sorts
of like experiences this is someone that
has tons many many years of experience
that can then add to this peer-to-peer
learning
i think also going back to that
intergenerational idea
um
you know there are younger people that
can teach older people things as well
and so that experience of kind of the
back and forth peer-to-peer learning is
really powerful
um i think
the mooc
the what a plant knows there's one of
our members who said that you know she
connected with her biologist son-in-law
over thanksgiving dinner
about this mooc and they had this really
great conversation and so the ability
that this learning environment and this
like new knowledge allows people to
connect with people in their social
networks i think that's really cool for
older people too right it gives you some
common ground that you can talk about
intergenerationally at family events
um
and so you know we don't have the
capacity at all at berkeley to measure
direct health benefits at this time but
as i said earlier like i think that
would be a really interesting thing for
someone to study on a large scale um to
see like what are cognitive benefits or
health benefits or from you know taking
a mooc as an intervention
finally dropouts
what five to ten percent of enrollees
actually complete a mooc it's pretty
abysmal completion scores depending on
the mooc of course
um
so there's been some talk
at this conference around motivation and
i don't think you could find a more
highly motivated group than this
most of them said if it weren't for the
ability to kind of vent their
frustrations and have that in class time
and have troubleshooting
that they probably wouldn't have
completed the course
so if we focus on
usability and accessibility and the
technology of these moocs we can prevent
dropouts in this group
so yesterday sharif halawa from stanford
was talking about his research findings
of analyzing a big data set that was
saying that you know a contributing
factor to dropout
they include lack of social support
technical challenges lack of
encouragement and lack of time
if you think about it lack of time is
not going to be as big of an issue for
many groups of older adults right they
might have more time they might be in
retirement that might not be such a big
issue
and so those other contributing factors
are things that mooc platforms can
control we can't control people's time
and so if we focus on you know this
motivation as a factor if we focus on
lack of encouragement and these
technical challenges we can access this
whole group with moocs
finally going back to that blended
learning and social support as i said
this was a really important factor
um
you know finding ways there's been a lot
of discussions conferences as well of
like the social aspects and so
i think that
it's not necessary that it had to happen
in person i think that especially as we
have other
you know
as this year's past and we have people
that are more technologically savvy kind
of aging then that's going to create a
situation where we could do things like
google hangouts and walk people through
how to do that and i think that you know
finding ways that people can do more
face-to-face virtual connection would be
just as good in a lot of ways i don't
think that it has to happen in a
classroom setting necessarily
um finally content i haven't talked much
about it um we found that users were
mostly interested in filling in their
gaps of knowledge our physicist was
really interested in taking humanities
courses our psychologists really wanted
to get into more of the physical
sciences and so the like sheer array of
moocs available was really exciting for
them um and so i think content-wise
there's no generalization i can say
and i don't think we should be doing
that
i think that mostly it's it's usability
and accessibility they're the main the
main things
um so this is one of our over 80
learners um she had profound hearing
loss has profound hearing loss
and
her feelings
moocs are not made for people like me
um so her name is k patricia cross she
goes by pat and she's a uc berkeley
emeritus professor
for the last 50 years she's been a
leading scholar of adult education
perfect candidate for a mooc wouldn't
you think
um
she
uses her hearing aids and she adjusted
the speaker volume as high as it could
go
but she still had trouble following
along because the fast pace of the
professor she didn't understand about
how you could slow down the pace on the
using the platform
we had to kind of show her oh you could
do closed captions
every single time she opened a new video
segment she had to take her mouse direct
it to the small little closed caption
building select it
and then click closed captions
it didn't remember her preferences it
wouldn't just play them automatically
she became very frustrated each time she
had to remember to do this each time it
would be something that would distract
her and the segment would kind of pass
her by
she also said that the instructor used
lots of hand waving and it was
incredibly distracting for her
especially when it would get in the way
of her mouth
and then that she wouldn't always look
at the camera and so it was this issue
of if the camera's not directly pointed
at the mouse she couldn't lip read
um and so pat stopped taking the mooc
she still came to the discussions but
she said this isn't for me
i think that's that's a huge loss
so you know i think that if we had some
of these in our ollie classrooms we have
a hearing loop that so people with
hearing aids can loop in
we have microphones that are required we
educate our instructors about the best
pedagogy for teaching to older people
and i think moocs can do this too
so really quickly some universal design
principles consistent design and
appearance on websites you know make
everything kind of look the same from
page to page
pay attention to contrast levels it's
easier to read things with the dark
background light text if you have a
light text on a like background it's
going to be hard for low vision
making sites so you can navigate them
only by keyboard if someone has a
disability where they can't easily use a
mouse
you're going to like erase them from
being able to use your site if you can't
get through it using a keyboard
clear and large text on any slides on
moocs and on the mooc platform itself
a camera with a clear view of the
instructor's mouth
i think mooc platforms should include an
accessibility statement stating that we
are trying to make our platform more
accessible and so if you have any
comments or questions or concerns please
notify us we're concerned about your
accessibility
finally
when you're designing the platform and
testing a mooc out test it for maximum
usability think about the lowest common
denominator think about the people that
might be using this you're the wide
variety of your audience and try to
design to that
these can all be found they're from the
university of washington so they have a
good universal design site
finally to engage and retain older
adults i think improving demonstrations
and help sections
coursera doesn't have a demonstration
they have a sort of like intro video and
then help where you have to click each
individual question
it's not super helpful because you have
to go back and forth
um
and so finding some sort of interactive
platform to do a demo edx has a pretty
good one
um
the other idea we had was anyone
remember this guy
from microsoft word
um having some sort of virtual mooc
assistant that as you went through and
you could turn it off for those that
didn't need it that you went through
would kind of guide you and direct you
and so you would know that hey this this
little paper clip icon is going to be
there to help me
much like some of these moocs have been
having mentoring programs what if
there's a peer guide program so someone
that might be younger and more
technologically savvy could connect with
someone and say hey if you have any
trouble let me know
and finally as i said educating
professors on the diversity of their
audience
final thing is thinking about building a
short quiz into the registration process
that asks people about any accessibility
issues and then adjusting the interface
for them
so then it would say you know oh well
here are the solutions based on your
quiz here are the adjustments that we'll
make you know does this sound good to
you do you want more high contrast you
need bigger text you need captions
always on and so you're rather than
making people do the work the platform
itself would be doing the work
finally we're going to be doing some
more mooc stuff at all at berkeley we're
using one from the edx platform on the
science of happiness we've had an
in-person course on that already so
we're going to be comparing the
evaluations of that to the kind of
blended learning
we're developing a mooc on healthy aging
one of our faculty members has been
doing that and then we'll be doing this
presentation at the american society on
aging conference
so
there we go sorry i went a little over
time
so i have some discussion questions
if unless anyone has any questions that
they
want to
think about talk about
what lifelong learners like to like
learn about all their lives long it's
like a tongue twister um
do a lot of the talk at this conference
has been about science
and i'm just curious whether you found
or whether other others have found it
there's a strong interest in among
certain age groups and maybe among older
learners in in the humanities or if
that's not evident i do know from book
publishing i mean if you look at
learning really writ large and you look
at nonfiction books that are bought or
even fiction books or crossword puzzles
or brain teasers or documentaries that
are watched or films that are you know
these are these are in effect learning
moments and people
interest
museum exhibits um people intersect with
these on a whole lot of different levels
and i think
it's it's interesting to know if you
know um
more about what older learners want to
learn about
so it's a good question
so
we do conduct
some we send out surveys basically every
couple of years and we're asking about
you know people's content
or what they'd like for content and it's
a pretty long list
it varies from year to year
and also from generation to generation
and so there's not really like a
generalization i can give
i know that especially in our over 80
group
we found that people are really future
focused and so they want to know like
what's coming up next less than like
history right
we found that kind of interesting too
because that's not what you would
necessarily think
we have these stereotypes that we have
and it's you know then it totally blew
us out of the water because they're
really they want to know what's
happening next
um
i think that it varies tremendously from
person to person
i have some copies of our fall 2014
course catalog so you can look at some
of the courses that we offer
and we do have a committee that's made
up of ali members and so if a faculty
member has an idea for a course they
have to kind of get through the
committee first
and then also you know we try to draw
from to we've just included sports in
our curriculum we're trying to find ways
to incorporate more men
because of that 70 30
you know
ratio of women to men
and so
yeah it's it's a hard question to answer
succinctly um i know you know if you
email me i can give you some more
information on that because i don't know
off the top of my head but i can share
with you just some of the numbers that
we have from some of our our past
surveys
yeah
sure
as far as
so you know we are actual so the in the
winter 2014 course um on the history of
mostly future education we started like
a week late into that and so but we went
through synchrony as far as like asking
people to complete the week the week
before and then we would have class
discussion on friday
so the new um
each week it would come out on monday
and then we'd say
okay
it's always it's always coming out of
the university the
university's
scheduled not to the not to the people
and you've got out there uh huge numbers
book clubs
that could serve as
mooc clubs you get six you know six set
uh boot you know six-section move
you get a book club that comes together
and watches it together and talks about
it together
uh or they can watch it at home
uh and then come in and talk about it
the way that they do book calls you've
also got
scans and participatory
of retirement homes
absolutely of people that are naturally
together
and can can customers
very different approach to thinking
about this but it turns into a move
because they're going to be massive
numbers of people
of course
uh massive numbers of people would look
at it and it also is open so it's a real
mooc
and i know um at one of the kind of
retirement communities where some of our
members live they did have
sort of a focus on moocs and they had a
discussion group around a mooc there as
well
but that was on i'm not sure if they did
it at the same time that that was
running that was something that was
separate from us but i think that that's
a really good point of like there are
natural meeting places where people
could go
and have these sort of like book clubs
or we have interest circles at ali and
we did stress to them you know when we
were selecting the moocs that it doesn't
have to happen
you know that you could do something
that happened in you know september of
2012 and mooc that started then and it
just so happens that the ones we
selected were happening at the same time
yes so um
because the audience that we're looking
for is corporate learners
and adult learners in what we're
creating our mood for so it would be
helpful if you could say a little bit
more about how you position the idea of
engaging with the move or even just
participating with this audience because
i see it as a real kind of extreme end
of marketing and positioning something
that and so would be a little bit easier
to do with corporate learners but it
would be interesting to see how we learn
so they would actually participate in
positions
we did a
moocs 101
um we went through
and actually went through the edx and
the coursera videos that they have
we had it up on a big screen and walked
everyone through we kind of showed
people of the actual mooc we signed in
and since it had already started we were
able to kind of go in and show them
and so
ann encouraged people you know they had
my email address and there was a another
ali member who had been assisting and
volunteered his time for this mooc
project um and
they could contact us if they were at
home and it was six o'clock and they
were like i have no idea how to sign in
they could call us and we could walk
them through the steps
they all have their own profiles yes
um and i'm
i know that at least one of them had
taken some moves before and so he kind
of already had their his sign in things
i don't think we helped them necessarily
with the like creation of the profiles i
think that was something that they were
able to to figure out and do
yeah
i think how big were the actual moves
that they joined and did they interact
mostly with each other
that's a good question
so the moocs i don't know the exact
numbers they were pretty massive um the
mooc that was put on by tel aviv
university on what a plant knows was
like excellent the production values
were really excellent the professor was
incredibly engaging the content was
interesting i mean
the one guy that had taken moocs before
was like this is i've never seen a mooc
like this you know it was a pretty
amazing
mooc for them to be doing
and so large numbers i mean these were
pretty and then the history
yeah i could look that up and and find
that out i'm not sure the in who
completed it versus who enrolled
um and then the other one
was actually a very interesting so there
was
a
blended learning environment going on
through that one in which and this was
at duke university i believe
um
and so they actually had the classroom
instructor and she was having a class
but they were also taking the mooc and
then there were all these other groups
taking the mooc and it was about kind of
the history and future of education so
it incorporated moocs
and it was
again like a pretty large group
um
and then as far as the like interactive
elements
we didn't get a whole lot of positive
feedback about the usage of forums um
again the most of the feedback was like
yeah i know it's there but like no one's
told me the best way to use it no one's
walked me through this i don't
understand these features
i don't understand you know like if i
post something up
who's you know like who sees that does
everyone see that there's a lot of sort
of like questions
and we had one member who
he actually did all of the like there
were these optional essays
he completed all of them
never heard anything back
and so he spent all this time doing
these essays and then was like where did
they go you know i i haven't gotten any
feedback i haven't gotten any peer
anything and so for him that was really
frustrating
um and so he kind of withdrew from those
interactive elements after that and he
said you know
a mooc's not like a classroom course
like this is like reading a book
you know
which is frustrating i know for people
that are designing because we want them
to be
interactive like that's this idea is
like they're interactive that it's not
this passive learning
but if people aren't understanding or
don't feel like they have the proper
guidance in like accessing these
interactive elements then it does sort
of become this more passive
you know so
yeah so the second mooc did have an
option i believe where you could pay for
a certification from it or something
like that um our learners are not that's
those are not motivating factors for
them
they
i think if anything to have a grade
would be a deterrent for a lot of our
older learners
in terms of
he wanted to get just some feedback or
at least know someone was reading his
essay not you know get an a on it um and
so because that's like they're learning
for the sake of learning rather than you
know for
a grade or for a certification
um although i think you know we've had
some discussions with
the folks over at mozilla about badges
and looking at at badges because that
might be something that people are
interested in because then they could
say you know at those thanksgiving
dinners like
i got this badge this is what i took you
know you never know what the
you know how people would react
to the entire class
i mean how many of the other people in
the class were in these two age groups
and
certainly um
a lot of older people that are looking
for at least
career credentials because they're ready
to go get a teaching certificate and do
something different than they did for
the first half of their life and
i think and that we just find those in
regular classes absolutely you're trying
to
get a certification or something like
that
yeah and i would say to your point too
that they're you know
i use this term older adult
talking about a range of like 50 to 90.
and so within that there's these little
you know differing like stages of life
and so someone that's you know 50 to 65
50 to 70 might be looking for second
career might still be doing their first
career
you know and so
because of the way that we were looking
at older learners and the way that we
were doing it in the over 80 group that
was the feedback that we got and so it
is important to know that many of the
people taking the moocs were you know in
this group where they're not looking for
certification or second careers
but i think that that's definitely true
for for younger generations
survey but we don't ask people's age and
we deliberately decided not to do that
and so my question is for the group to
see if you offer a free course survey do
you ask how old your students are
you do
i mean canvas asks
i guess you can shut it off if you don't
want to ask them and of course they
don't have to fill it up
you have the age distribution
why did you decide not to
because we tried well we first did our
survey was on it and it was really
really long and we knew people wouldn't
complete the survey if it was that long
and so when we went back and looked at
what questions
we wanted to remove we decided that
we wouldn't ask any question
that wouldn't impact future iterations
of the course we only asked questions
that affected our instructional design
and age just didn't
didn't come across for us as one of the
things
that we could adjust because we
were confined to what coursera will let
us do
so you know
short of
editing every video twice
which was financially not possible i'm
not sure
what we would have done
interesting
yeah i mean i think that that's
and your point is important too around
surveys people don't if you have a
really long survey
my thought in asking about challenges
might be that if someone does have those
challenges they'd be more apt to fill it
out and so we would get that information
and i think that you know
age might be something
that would be i think when you register
for coursera
they ask that
um
i believe so um i haven't done it in a
while but i think it's an optional
question it might be like the year you
were born
um
i i think so don't quote me on that
exactly that's not yours yeah yeah and
so
you know that yeah so i in doing your
own survey it's gonna you're gonna have
a different data set yeah
okay
what are the challenges for you to
try to get that age demographic to
participate
in the course as opposed to your
sure um we had some people that said
they weren't interested in online
learning um that it was not a platform
that they wanted to explore um and some
people that were incredibly like
interested and passionate about it
i think that
a lot of people anecdotally take our
courses they might not lead with this
but it's something that we've found
throughout the years because of the
social aspect of it because they're
friends taking a course because
they met these people and they're going
out for coffee afterwards and they know
that wednesday is going to be this
course and so they're going to have that
you know social time
moocs don't necessarily people don't
think about the social aspects of moocs
and so i think that might have been
a barrier in people saying like online
learning i don't want to do that you
know this is not necessarily what i'm
here for
um
i would think also
you know in
a lot of what people like about ollie is
that
we have some professors and some
instructors that are really well known
and offer repeat courses
and so the thing with a mooc is
we can't offer any
instructor reviews we can't have the
mooc instructor come to our open house
and talk to everyone about how important
it is to join their course or why they
might like it and so people can't really
see what the fit would be until they
start taking the mooc
so
why are you guys here
if anyone wanted if i can pose a
question to that what interested you in
thinking about older learners
don't all go first
i have several reasons i wrote a book on
older adult careers people in their 80s
90s there are people over 100 that are
still being paid
to do work and um
virtual ability and nobility
on design if you don't know virtual
ability created a handicapped version of
second life
um and has a lot of warfaces who are
involved in second one which is really
interesting and a lot of that that
universal design wheelchair ramps all
that works to help women strollers
is just such a great principle
um
and we do have a lot of students in the
community colleges the community college
i taught at
had sort of an average age of 40. i
don't have as many 60 year olds
in my classes so
community college is a place
when the economy goes down everybody
goes to college
and then when it comes back up they've
acquired some skills or some sort of
issues
and the moocs are really good the
california virtual campus
the most popular classes are for our
police science and
law because the police environment is
going to have such erratic schedules
to do that make
public sense
which are big
first responders in big catholic
uh communities and there are a lot of
people say i'm sick of working out so
i'm going to go become a forest ranger
for them my second career and that's
what they do
we work for the smithsonian and so we
have a large media outlet so we look at
the demographics of our table channel
you know
average age of 53. we have 8 million
readers to our magazine it's an average
age 57
and when we look at
our activities on the web while
18 to 32 year olds is about 40
we have about 30 that are 55 and older
and so we see
a very interesting demographic there
that
has capacity with our media properties
to really like
digital is modules for public servants
in developing countries and something
that we've learned about this learner
group is that they bring a lot of
experience to their training and so the
digital training needs to respect their
experience and knowledge
and build it in somehow to the tone the
content and the activities in the
platform and so i feel like this is
similar
to
aging adults and that their experience
is a value in the learning process and
there needs to be some ways to bring
that in
great thank you
i
am
interested in
mcdonald's because i work here at mit
and when we look at the demographics for
some of the stem courses it's very
heavily weighted in people's pre-college
and
very young people who are
making up on their first career
and it just occurred to me and something
you know a lot of what you say is that
there's this amazing
potential for for older adults to take
courses for very different reasons than
people take them in their late teens
just wanted to find out more about it so
that i can maybe have a voice when we
talk about it in my job there's
that there are demographics that can
really do it for very different reasons
and what we would think
the the big population that there's this
sort of long tail of people out there
great wonderful thank you
we're actually looking at this segment
as one of our targets for 2015.
um so we're doing some research at the
university to
determine
you know what we can do how we can do it
uh we think open definitely has a spot
you know with this group because of the
accessibility
the self-paced the low cost lower no
cost which is what their interest this
group is interested in
so we're looking at this as one of our
target segments okay and where are you
from kaplan university well great
wonderful thanks
i'm currently working on
online
will you ask about their age
all right thank you
guys in the back yeah hi my name
extension we is
our organization implement the open
index environments um and
it is interesting challenge and it seems
like similar to
many user experience problems we see on
the web
and uh
i've seen it especially in in older
people they really like the ipad
platform and i heard many stories about
you know my my grandmother got her first
he sent her first email through an ipad
so i think this is a similar kind of
problem that we're interested to solve
in the same way
the technology seems like especially
based on what i've seen here last couple
of days the similar the technology is a
little premature
for that uh
just because you know the ui is not
there yet the customization is not there
yet
uh but seems like as soon as they uh
specifically edx but the other providers
when they open the
user experience for third parties to
develop their own kind of platforms and
and um
applications to consume the content that
opens up to a lot of interesting
opportunities with this population
great
yeah so that's
interesting too that you mentioned about
um the kind of the mobile devices and
the ipads because there was one of our
members who was saying that
he was able to kind of go on his
treadmill and just take his ipad there
and do the mooc and do the segments as
that happens and so i think that that's
definitely like making sure that mobile
platforms
um are responsive in the same way as a
laptop or a desktop platform is
definitely important for this group
great point
let's say thanks this headline
um because i'm interested in
um for experts
so and this is why i was anticipating
older could be this kind of age range
let's say 45 plus to
let's say retirement because i sit on a
professional aspect
um but the many learnings here as well
about it's about the segmentation so
maybe the because i was wondering 50 and
older
so yeah some i mean sometimes i think
it's about the adoption of technology
so because i think you mentioned a very
interesting point
uh
people and technology i mean sometimes i
have colleagues there between 40 and 50
i think um they are in the technology
adoption of of
maybe some some very
another generation while i have in the
same cohort people who behave like
gen y or jen
with the millenniums
so i think this is a very important
point and
this is what i got over the last
48 hours over here that the whole
development is very young so it's about
the customization it's about the
definitions it's about the segmentation
in terms of different age groups and
basically i'm back so i'm looking on an
expert so how moocs basically could work
for
let's say in my background for i
iata international airline association
um with a bunch of experts iko
for
big hotel groups which still train
individually
on their hotels so i mean i'm looking in
these aspects of moocs
it's basically probably more community
based yeah interesting though
and i think that's also a good point you
know we had people who are in their
early 50s
and they did by and large struggle less
than people who are in their late 80s
as a function of
how long you've had access to and how
early you adopted technology
it might be that you know for some of
the 80 year olds this was they had a
computer or they just got an iphone you
know that these were things are there
you know a child had bought them
an ipad and so they might not have been
using it quite as long
and the point being that
you know in an ideal world we'd be able
to have platforms that they could also
use but yeah i think that was that was a
big difference
and something to to think about
yes
it strikes me that you know just like
with
all different audiences you know when we
talk about motivation
they're highly motivated but in fact you
could have
uh sort of a newly retired
63 year old who would actually be highly
motivated to net you know who's lost
sort of the professional
network that they find every day going
to their job but would be highly
motivated to meet with other experts and
potentially sort of almost have a second
career in using the expertise in some
sort of network and then you would have
someone else who
just cared about the lifelong learning
and the social aspect and someone else
who actually might want to mentor
or provide you know the retired physics
professor who actually might get a huge
sense of motivation out of helping other
students in sort of a team-based
environment you know so this is where it
kind of comes down to asking the
questions
it's as much about
you know what you're looking to get out
of it as it is even your age but
absolutely and then yeah there's more of
the technical issues around
you know taking care of accessibility
which also can be independent of age as
well absolutely that's a really good
point thank you
yes
i just wanted to
make a comment about the story you told
about kate patricia cross
because it was so touching to me it
really stayed with me what you said
about how she interacted with the mooc
as well as the meeting and it was
fascinating to me that
even though she had trouble
keeping up with the move she still came
to the face-to-face meetings
and it kind of signaled to me the power
of face-to-face interaction what people
are talking about you know book groups
and ways of having pure
connection just reinforces that there's
something very um
effective about that in fact the fact
that we're having a media conference
about moocs and we're choosing to do it
just the case so another
indication that there's something really
valuable here that um if we can leverage
that in some way people talk about using
you know senior residences or other
areas where people congregate i think
that really helps
um with retention and just all aspects
of education
the other thing i just wanted to
comment on and you just reminded me of
this when you were talking about sort of
people at age 50 as opposed to people at
age 80 and the sort of difference where
they as far as like their tendency to be
more or less comfortable with technology
this is one thing that fastest and
fascinates me about older populations is
that we have a group of people
between 60 and 80 who still remember
what it was like to use a slide rule and
who still remember having a manual
typewriter and who still
remember the first time they had a
calculator in their hands and it's so
what's that yeah really
so they um
they're really people who have been in
the pre and the post and they have so
many
fascinating experiences to share with us
around what it's like to to exist in the
world that's a technological world as
opposed to a world where they existed
without it and a part of me
feels that we need to mine that before
they're gone they'll be gone in 20 years
and we will everybody nobody will
remember
what it was like before a computer but
there are people who who do and and they
have so many important stories to tell
us and i hope that like the ollie group
sees the people they serve as a resource
oh absolutely for us around learning and
how we interact with devices
absolutely yeah yeah and i the other
thing is you know in terms of
it would be great if we had i know that
there's probably websites and platforms
and things where people could kind of um
interview each other or like record some
of those stories because i agree i think
that there's a lot of history that's
lost
and especially with the rapid pace that
technology is changing
um
i
it's i i have a 19 year old sister and
there's just certain things that she's
like wait what's that like you know like
there was a time before you just had
everything in a pocket on your iphone
and you had you know because she's just
grown up with that and it's a completely
different world for her
um
and i have no doubt that she would be
able to go on a mooc and figure it out
in two seconds and be enrolled and be on
the forum and and doing all of that
um
to your point too about the face-to-face
interactions um
i think that's also i agree that that's
important
for people who can't leave their homes
i think we should be leveraging and
looking into
more of the things like google hangouts
so people can have that interaction
because it's a very different experience
than typing on a computer and seeing a
list of answers to questions if you can
look into someone else's eyes even over
you know this virtual world that we live
in
and so i would really like to explore
that at ollie in this next
um
mooc kind of phase that we move into is
like what would be the difference is if
we were to have one class that where we
met in a hangout instead of in the
classroom and what people's takeaways
and experiences with that because i
think that that's
definitely in finding ways that that we
can continue that
idea of the face-to-face interaction but
not necessarily having to be in the same
location
anything else
one of the people i know in california
has in paige's mother
east coast has real part of vision
problems and she also
so she gets her a device that you know
like the kindle you blow up
they probably tested it on college-age
students age 19
18-22
like most of our research is done
um yeah i think that's that's another
excellent point is that you know you
might be able to blow up the text but if
you're
like on the coursera in order to find
the help button you scroll to the very
bottom and it's this little tiny thing
and then you go into there and then you
find you can't search like coursera demo
nothing comes up if you do a google
search of that and so yeah making sure
that icons are big and like
why not put a big help thing on the
right hand corner that's the first thing
you see in a big button you know why not
make things so that because everyone
will benefit from that
so
all right yeah
from from this morning talk about the
design of
of basically it's the web design at the
end
yeah
we still
um
technology is still supposing this is
for young people but it is not useful
has to be consistent over the whole
life cycle
yeah i mean i guess when people though
when the designers visions themselves
start to go or when they start having
these issues or if someone has some
experience with older parents that they
might have that in mind but we all
really should
um because it just you know what pat was
saying when she was saying this isn't
made for me like that was a really
stigmatizing experience for her
to go you know there's just no one
thought about this no one thought about
it it's hearing loss it's something that
happens to so many people as they get
older
you know and so to have that experience
already
you know by losing your hearing you get
left out of so many conversations you
get left out of so much
you know there's connections between
hearing loss and depression between
hearing loss and cognitive issues and so
if everywhere you turn including this
like inclusive idea of providing
universal education has that as a
barrier it's really problematic
for moocs i mean we have this topic of
accessibility in the web community but
it's still missing in here
definitely
great well i hope you guys all
got some good stuff to take away and
take back to your respective places and
thank you so much for coming this is
great thank you
you